The next case is we pick this v at random, and it just so happens that it partitions
to something bigger than K--so this is case III here.
What happens at this point? Well, all the values get separated out.
all the ones smaller than v end up over here,
and all the ones bigger than v end up over here.
And we haven't really solved the problem yet but we have made it a lot smaller.
Consider at this point the list of the L’ from here to here.
This is a list of elements that Top K of this list is going to be exactly the Top K of the original list
because the values that we're throwing out here can't possibly be in the Top K.
What we can do at this point is look again for the Top K,
but now just do it on the sublist of L[0:rank(v)].
By picking v, we've actually just made this problem smaller. So great.
Now we've handled two of the three cases. One case, it's completely solved.
And another case, we have a smaller version of the same problem.
What about the third case? So the third case is when the rank(v) is smaller than K.
We do a partition and the v that we happened to pick is off to the left here.
So what that means is we've now separated the list into elements that are smaller than this v value
over here and elements that are bigger than this v value over here.
And what do we know about this initial list? Well, we know that this actually is in the Top K.
But we don't know about what's going on with the rest of the world over here.
But we learned enough to have made some progress.
Again we're going to recurse. Now what do we need to do?
Well, this is the list that we are still unsure about.
And there could be some off by ones in here but just to give you the basic idea
from the rank of v, from this position here to the end of the list is what we care about.
But we don't want to find the Top K of this. We want to find the Top K - rank(v). Why?
Because we already know these elements here are already in the Top K.
We only really need to care about what's left. The K - rank(v) that we haven't found yet.
Those are the three cases that we care about, and we ought to be able to code this up
and actually find the Top K in this list.